all right so I I have to do a speech on
Dark Knight that it's not scripted on
the page you know it's just like yeah
the the mayor says if you were is this
and that I'm and I'm thinking oh so you
know what I'll just write something you
know and because I'll give the speech
and then the Joker's supposed to kill me
or try to kill me and I'm like I better
write something so I wrote something
here I am writing Chris Nolan's group
and so I get to I'd done a scene the day
before I get to the hotels in Chicago
and uh all of a sudden there's a speech
waiting for me there and I'm going
they're giving me the speech now and
it's like this long speech and I go I
had this idea of what I was going to say
I was like why was I thinking that that
was ever gonna go but now I was like no
I got a mess I can memorize that yeah
and it was like 10 o'clock at night I
was like were you stressed yeah were you
nervous of course anxiety it's massive
and that's like there's gonna be 1200
extras how did you do it awfully so I I
was up all night learning it finally I I
remember being there with 1200 you know
extra background workers there in the
middle of the financial district of
Chicago I'm supposed to give this speech
you know and then he's using an IMAX
camera which is like 200 Grand a take is
what I'm thinking like these things are
massive and so expensive and uh and sure
enough I'm doing this Pro after walking
this parade with uh with Maggie
Gyllenhaal and you know and then and so
I I go to Maggie it's like Maggie can
you just look at this I don't even know
her I was like I should see if I'm off
book here so I'm like running lines with
Maggie as we're walking and finally I
get to the podium and I Gotta Give the
speech and I don't want to read off I
was like that's so late they had it
though they edit there if I wanted to
read this I would have done that I would
have no but then it's like then you
don't really know it I gotta read this
[__] but that's what a mayor would do he
kind of read things and go hey or or
usually they have those prompters where
you you know you know they would cut
away yeah you know but I was like but no
but I didn't want it so I wanted it I
wanted it to be so sure enough I'm like
going off and then like on the first
take like I kind of go up and then all
of a sudden
I'm going up and there's 1200 people and
then there's Chris Nolan there's got a
iPad that he's suing it seeing it on an
iPad not far off the set and then I'm
like oh sorry sorry can we go again he's
like and he goes nesters it's just me
it's just me and I go Chris it's exactly
it's just you it's Christmas oh my God
but it was in that moment he really
truly relaxed me and I was like this guy
is like amazing so you know it was like
all of a sudden I was like dude you're
super cool and uh and that was that that
was pretty it was cool for Maggie to
read with you yeah how cool is that